my throat's closing up
yeah oh God why
[Music]
why hey what's going on everybody for
first we Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and at
long last we're joined by my chicken
fueled talk show host sister in arms
Amilia de molenberg she's the host of
chicken shop date for my money the best
fried chicken talk show on the internet
check out Amilia molenberg YouTube
channel to binge the catalog and while
you're there treat yourself to the
exceptional and underrated Amelia's
cooking show I know I did but in the
meantime the wings of death Amilia de
molenberg welcome to the show hi hello
how you feeling going into this I'm I am
feeling great yeah I can feel it no I'm
I don't really consume spice in my life
so I'm I'm quite nervous I'd rather be
on a first date than here right now
that's for
sure
[Music]
okay Cheers
Cheers
cool that's hotter than I thought it
would be for the first one not going to
lie not going to lie I thought sorry SM
every I feel I thought you would it
would be less heat than that so
that's
[Music]
alarming so I remember years ago sorry I
forgot that you were going to be asking
me questions I literally just forgot
that when you just start ask that
question I was like what's happening
alarmed by it yeah I know we throw a lot
at you here on the show Okay cool so I
remember years ago shooting a video in a
chicken shop with the chicken
connoisseur near Tottenham and
distinctly remember these hordes of
youths outside banging on the Windows
begging for a picture I'm curious what's
the most chaotic scene that you've
experienced or maybe even created doing
a show like chicken shop date in such a
unique environment ooh it's true because
everyone's always queuing up outside to
get their chicken from the chicken shop
and like uh now we actually have
security outside the shop um to sort of
stop people from not trying to see me
it's from trying to get some chicken
like that's l what people are uh are
trying to do when they're trying to get
to the chicken shop we've had like lots
of people banging on um the doors like
rattling the outside of it oh with
Jennifer Lawrence Paparazzi followed her
oh to the shop and so there was like
photos in the Daily Mail of like
Jennifer Lawrence E exiting a chicken
shop in edere Road and um which was just
crazy to me cuz I grew up like on like
one road away from Ed Road and just the
kind of full circle of like then there
being pictures in the Daily Mail of like
Jennifer Lawrence leaving a chicken shop
um is crazy but yeah it's it depends
what time day is
[Music]
really blistered is a terrible word
isn't
[Music]
it I'm sorry my hand is shaking it's so
embarrassing happen
listen no matter what you're going
through on this show no no matter what
happens way crazier has happened
here Amelia okay okay yeah I mean I I've
heard we don't know what's going to
happen next we've already done two I
like that more by the way than the first
one do you ever a tell for when a guest
is relaxed and engaged and if so how
early can you recognize it
ooh good question um I feel like it
doesn't happen at the very beginning I
feel like halfway through then the guest
becomes more relaxed and I feel like
after I make them laugh once then I
think they become more warm and relaxed
at the same time it can go off to a
really really good start like I'm asking
questions they're saying really funny
things back they're being really
engaging and then in the in the middle
it will just have this big LOL and then
I'll like bring out a prop and I'll be
like why don't you play this tiny
keyboard or like why don't you like why
don't you strum on this ukulele or like
I've got this random like magnetic um
diary that can open with the sound of
your voice and I feel like that then
gets people in the zone again um so yeah
I feel like uh it's sort of after after
the first joke is when I feel like
people kind of become at
[Music]
ease oh okay I like passion fruit
underrated
fruit nice has it got passion fruit in
it like real passion fruit it does is
that coming through for you
no um maybe it'll hit me again way
better than the first one what's going
on with this first one is that is that
the first one your own one
yeah not sure like maybe you should go
back to the drawing board a little bit
maybe like maybe I don't know if that
one is that great the first one it's all
right okay you can you can you can say
it how it is on this show cool but I see
that the fourth one is yours too so
right so maybe we can redeem ourselves
hopefully your eyes Amilia there we go I
really like that that's really nice got
a sweet level to it favorite so far
favorite so far I think so yeah I know
it would be what do you see as the power
of stating the obvious or asking simple
questions that is everything really I
think that's when I think about it I
feel like maybe that's one of my
strengths is is just stating stating the
obvious saying the thing that everyone's
been thinking you know
like you're bold and you are and it's
amazing and that was when I'm when I'm
asking you questions that's what one of
my lines of questioning and it's like
what does it feel like to be B hair yeah
you know that's what everyone's thinking
an exhilarating experience that not
everyone can always feel too so I like
to be an ambassador for the lifestyle
it's true so yeah I think that a lot of
Comedy comes from um just saying
something that um is obvious but then I
guess the the trick is like it's obvious
to me but that might not be obvious to
everyone else and I feel like that's
where um the maybe some of the like
special qualities of the interview comes
[Music]
about it's one of yours so it's going to
be good you know what though if you
don't like it like you didn't like the
first one go ahead and let us have it
all right
okay
H more of like a smokey Barbe mhm I love
tomatoes that's for sure but I can see
in your face you're lukewarm on the
sauce I know you I can see it I don't
know maybe it's like wait it's a bit
like ketchupy and I do love ketchup is
that an insult it's a cool hot sauce
like ketchup I'm so sorry why don't you
just State the ABV it's called how you
see it I'm terrible at like food in
general like I'm not a foodie I've got I
I'm really not that adventurous like I'm
I'm I'm really bad one of my favorite
that's why do a nuggets and chip show oh
yeah that's true one of my favorite
episodes is Florence peon because I
loved how for every bite she took she
like had a recipe recipe from hot sauce
and you were like writing notes like I
need to do this um yeah so did you ask
me a question no not yet but I was about
to if you're ready for it yep I'm ready
so I'm of the opinion that the red
carpet interview is the most
intimidating and unnerving assignment
that you can possibly get in media and
it was a sentiment that was echoed when
I sat down with Alexa Chung she called
it everyone's worst nightmare but it's
clearly a challenge that you've embraced
how do you even prepare for an
environment so chaotic when there are
literally hundreds of personalities and
potential variables involved shout Alexa
Chong by the way the pat of the show
yeah yeah yeah she's amazing yeah cuz
the her do pop world then inspir this
not Inspire this but yeah I know um red
carpet interviews yes I love them I
really feel I really thrive in that
environment of of the challenge of red
carp intervie because it's true it is a
very challenging environment me and
whoever I'm writing with sometimes my
sister sometimes another writer will
literally go through the list and we'll
think of four or five questions for each
celebrity for the Golden Globes there
was over a 100 names and so I'll prep
for everyone and then you just hope for
the best to see who comes your way and
also where you your position on the
carpet is so important um because if
you're sort of not in eyeline of the
talent then it can be really difficult
to get an interview like when I did the
Brits um the Brit Awards sorry sped um
Ed it happens on this show um when I did
the Brit Awards Ed Sheron was doing no
press and I was in his eyeline on the
red carpet so I literally looked at him
and I went hi and I just interviewed him
and so he came over and his security was
like no he's not doing any any press and
he was like no I'm going to speak to
Amelia so it's all about getting in the
ey line really shout out to Ed yeah
shout out to Ed all right Amilia are you
ready to move on here to the halfway
mark yes you are doing great still on
your heels this is the uh jablo Power
jab okay Power
jab
okay
it's a step up yeah a better friend
would have warned
you spicy spicy yeah For Better or Worse
that's how the show's formatted spicy
okay um cool I don't know am I meant to
say what it tastes like you don't
there's no you don't have to do anything
about okay I can't really tell what it
tastes like it's just it's intense it is
intense though I can see it yep yeah but
you're doing great okay so in 2021 you
launched a series on Channel 4 called
celebrity Rebrand where you would would
counsel other onair personalities from
Anna Richardson to Jimmy Carr on the
ways that they could Elevate their
career profiles so with that in mind
what I want to do is channel Amelia Deen
BG brand Visionary for some existential
questions that we've been having
internally about hot ones for the ways
that maybe we can Elevate this brand
okay okay so we
began for starters fix the sauce get a
new
sauce we've had this black curtain 1980s
C access set basically since the
beginning do you have any ideas for ways
that we can modernize or transform the
set here ooh you know what I I actually
quite like it because the thing with
this is it's so much easier to access
than a chicken shop like you you can
sort of pop up most places where you
need a chicken shop I cannot pop up you
know I need to get the talent into a
chicken shop and that is actually been
quite a struggle like throughout the
kind of Journey of chicken shop dat so I
actually don't really have any notes on
the set um because I think that it's
very smart of you we nailed it you
nailed it yeah how about wild
over-the-top exaggerated out ofc control
hand gestures do they have any place in
an interview setting I don't know well
maybe if it's your yeah I mean you think
do you think yours are that over the top
you know Jake Gyllenhaal was saying I
have too much over he said I have too
much upper body no I think it's good I
feel like you know you're you're dressed
in black you're in a black set you know
you need to like have something
going on male hands male hair
transplants for onair personalities yay
or no
no no I don't think so I don't think so
maybe you yeah but I think in
[Music]
general can we sorry can we have a
moment I'm like I can't believe this I'm
halfway through I mean but I feel like
this is where it gets tough I don't want
to celebrate too soon it's when the
guest start dancing like that is the
exact moment that it goes flying off the
rails Ty oh God I didn't I shouldn't
have done that no I'm just happy that I
I'm just I'm just happy to be here I am
you know who would have thought who
would have thought not me actually me no
I didn't think we one day we'd meet I
knew we'd do it eventually okay all
right so this is the whiskey smoked
ghost here in the six
[Music]
spot
okay
H I like the initial flavor it does grow
something going to happen isn't it
something's going to happen I know I
know but you're on top of it you're
doing good it's kind of kicking for me
right now it is okay yeah but look at
you it's fine you're holding my hand
through this whole thing it's okay mhm
I've also been kind of I I can't get it
on my lips oh it's coming there's
another thing now what happening the
tongue yeah little time release
sometimes on I haven't actually had any
water yet should I do that I've noticed
that
should I do that if you need to okay
I'll join you at the
[Music]
party they all got goat oh no that's
ghost sorry I like this all goat
themed this actually is kind of a goat
themed lineup though we have like an
angry goat Two Goats we have multiple
goats on the
lineup so prior your work on chicken
shop date I know that you fashion
journalism at Central St Martin's from
Zoolander to double we's Prada Bruno
clueless and Beyond is there a film that
you think best sises the world of
fashion
oo I think davil West pra is one of the
greatest films of all time like in like
it's one of my favorite films um like
the that all the actors cast perfectly
um that monologue that Merl stre does
about C the color of Cerulean is like
one of the
greatest pieces of art ever in cinema um
I think it's a great depiction of not
just of the fashion industry but also
just a brilliant film pound for pound
what do you think is the best fit that a
guest has gotten off on chicken shop
date ooh best outfit okay um that is a
really good question koi radical I think
came in an amazing outfit like I think
it was like a cashmere sweater maybe or
some kind but he's so stylish and um he
always looks amazing um so he maybe is
one of the best dressed I've had on the
show all right
Amelia I see on the board wing wing wing
wing wing nugget yeah we have nuggets
for de bomb Beyond Insanity okay right
ready ready how sorry how much what how
much you got to eat as much as you eat
but I would go small yeah I would go
[Music]
small this one I don't think you have to
wait around for it'll oh yeah almost
immediate almost immediate okay that is
like a weird that's weird that's
weird it's horrible my throat's posing
up okay I can put that down yeah put
that down it's just like tingling my
tongue is
tingling and it's like as I talk more
it's getting worse yeah and it's not
going to stop for the next couple
minutes yeah we're just going to be on
this roller coaster just going to
yeah good does that work good
yeah oo
yeah what would you say that someone's
chicken shop order says about them M oh
too much that helped um what do PE what
does someone chicken order say about
them yeah like are there any like
unforgivable pH
well people always say that like nuggets
and chips is a faux part but I actually
just think that means that you don't
care about what people think about you
and that you you know you live by your
own rules if you're ordering like
wings and chips or whatever maybe you're
just like a bit middle of the road sorry
like M like is in I don't if you have a
if you do a that was my order today yes
yes if you do a classic chicken shop
order maybe you just like sort of don't
really like to Branch out or you like
what you like how you feeling yeah I'm
feeling fine I'm feeling fine it's
uh it's it's
fine here we go
Amilia
sweet right and not a walk in the park
it's Sweet at First M and then has some
punches on the other side of it yeah but
after the bomb it's like a little you
know yeah it's like hitting that side of
my mouth and then that side of my mouth
it's like yo-yoing between it's like a
tennis match in my mouth of discomfort
of discomfort but I'm very impressed
with you Amilia with the uh with the
affect that you had coming in here I
know and then where you are now I know
it's cuz I don't ever I don't consume
spice like I'll never like like because
to me that taste it's like it's fine for
this circumstance of like me being like
okay we can do it but like in terms of
like a flavor to consume food yeah it's
like not an interest of mine well maybe
your preference is down here but your
tolerance way up here Amelia yeah maybe
sure so
sorry so I'm often asked you know what's
your favorite interview of all time that
you've done and I find it to be like an
impossible to answer questions sometimes
so I'm not going to go there with you
but I am curious what do you think has
been your most important interview which
interview do you think had the biggest
impact on the growth of your channel and
then which interview would you suggest
fans check out first if they're
unfamiliar with you okay um there's been
like a few that stand out I would say
um Jack haro's interview sorry
date um um was definitely a really
important one because feel like that was
like some people in America's first
taste of chicken shop date and also I
feel like it's quintessential like the
perfect date in my eyes because there's
like now I'm just going to sound like
funny but like I feel like there's a
chemistry there between us um and um he
sort of is charming and cheeky in a way
that like I really want the guests to be
and he's just so naturally funny and
charismatic the Lou through episode as
well a really important one because he's
a hero of mine and to get him on the
show the first time I ever meet him to
be on my show to interview my favorite
interviewer apart from you um was it was
just amazing moment so that was really
like important moment for me personally
and then there's been other ones like um
with UK rappers like AJ Tracy and H I've
sort of caught people at a time before
they really really became really big and
that is something that I always try and
do with the show is like it's not just
about getting like the biggest A-list
stars on that's NE never how it was in
the beginning it's about choosing guests
Who I Really respect their music um what
they what they stand for and people I
think that other people should know
about so so yeah those those two for
that reason as well all right Amelia
okay cool is this the last
one it is I don't want to leave should
we do it
again is this the X is the Peppa X you
tried the other day yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I should have brought up a
pet
okay like that yes that's perfect
actually that's textbook yeah okay
experience here we go
Amelia I do like
[Music]
you it's
cold it it's a cooling sensation
yeah that's right it catches me too I
think at this point it's pavlovian like
ever since I tried that pepper and now
when you just pick up a little bit of it
I'm taking right back I don't mind it
that spot with chili cloth look at you I
don't mind
[Music]
it wow cool I mean that is still burning
my mouth but like it it's not nice is it
no it's not not it's not you know and it
does have that kind of delayed reaction
to it but you know what here's the good
news Amilia I don't have a stunt or a
question here on Wing 10 I just have a
moment of appreciation you know I've
long admired you and your work for so
long and I feel this transatlantic
Kismet and what we do and uh this has
been such a moment that's so overdue and
appreciate the fans who've been very
vocal about peer pressuring us into a
room together but just uh the Bizarro
Chi fueled interview worlds that we live
in and the way that they've grown so
organically on either side of the pond
and then becoming friends with you all
along you know it just feels like a
great moment a bow on the present kind
of moment and with that out of the way I
have nothing left to do but roll out the
red carpet for you that's going to make
me cry because the wings didn't make me
cry but that might make me cry because
that was that was really such a lovely
thing of you to say because I totally
agree with everything that you've said
like it's been so amazing to see both of
our Journeys and how there's so many
similarities to what we do but we have
our own lane completely and I don't know
I'm such a fan of of your interview
style and how you've made it really your
own and how you get my favorite thing to
do is get a different side to a guest
and that's exactly what you do you're so
well researched and it's just really
like top tier you take it seriously and
so do I and it's just it's just been
amazing to be here today and thank you
for inviting me cuz I was waiting for
you to make the first move I know you
were I finally did and I hopped on the
plane and I came to London all right
came to London and usually I make the
first move okay well lucky me but you
know before the fans at home puke
watching us gush over each other let me
roll out the red carpet for you okay
this camera this camera this camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life what do I have going on in
my life I would actually like to use
this time um to just make a little
announcement to any um hot celebrities
watching this show I am available and
please slide into my DMs um because I'm
ready to date you um but only if you're
hot so yeah thank
you
[Applause]
woo I'm so happy that I did that I
honestly thought I was going to be
hospitalized like I actually thought my
sister my sister told me my sister is
such a big fan she wanted to come today
but she was working she was like I said
that you'd you told you'd invited me to
do this she was like I I don't think you
should do it it she was like don't do it
like it's not going to be worth it well
you can uh go home with the story to
tell her you proved her wrong I survived
we'll see what happens tomorrow when I'm
dressed as Mr Bean like on the
toilet oh thank you no you're the
best hot ones fans it's been years in
the making but at long last the next big
thing in Wings is finally here
introducing hot ones buffalo sauce our
SP SP on Buffalo is a rich and tangy
combo of cayenne peppers distilled
vinegar and yes real butter which means
that you can put hot ones buffalo sauce
directly on wings no mixing or melting
required it's the best damn buffalo
sauce I've ever had in my life but don't
take my word for it camera guy Bill
Buffalo's favorite song gives it to blaz
and thumbs up don't you Bill that's a
Buffalo Bill
guarantee heatness heatness.com that's
heatness.com to get your hands on the
brand new hot ones Buffalo sauuce
[Music]